Newark Liberty International Airport one
of the country's busiest is operating
normally this morning after a drone
forced it to shut down yesterday the
drone was seen flying about 3500 feet
now that's about nine times the legal
limit less than 20 miles from the
airport a pilot reported that it came
within feet of the plane that he was
about to land at the New Jersey Airport
Kris Van Cleave is at Washington's
Reagan National Airport with moral news
story Kris this scares me every time I
hear this story I feel it's an accident
waiting to happen good morning - good
morning Gail it is a huge and
increasingly a daily concern for pilots
police are still looking for whoever was
flying this drone as this becomes just
the latest in a string of incidents
that's worrying everyone who takes to
the skies around 5:00 yesterday evening
pilots approaching Newark Liberty
International Airport narrowly averted a
potential disaster the close call forced
the FAA to briefly hold all arrivals
into Newark leaving several flights
circling the runway they didn't tell us
anything like it we just like went
around but the pilot never mentioned
anything a recent study showed the
potentially severe impact of a drone
crashing into the wing of a small plane
while typically small a drone could tear
through the body of an aircraft they
shouldn't be flying near an airport
period you know if they do and they get
caught well they gotta pay the
consequence drone sightings like these
are becoming increasingly common with
the FAA now receiving more than a
hundred reports a month in December more
than a hundred thousand passengers were
stranded at London's Gatwick Airport for
about 36 hours after a pair of drones
flew within the airspace there and last
February a drone came dangerously close
to hitting a Frontier Airlines flight
over Las Vegas London Gatwick Airport
has now spent millions of dollars to buy
military-grade anti-drone equipment the
Newark incident caused several flights
to be delayed others had to divert to
other airports drones shouldn't be
flying above 400 feet are within 5 miles
of an airport without special permission
Noora not your birthday oh thank you
thanks for standing out there and the
colbus warning thank you